sie leben an den entlegensten orten am
anderen ende der welt
in einer fantastischen schiffsführers
uns zu
im wilden patagonia
[Musik]
wer fleisch bergen auf den falkland
inseln
dem größten kunst in den kindergarten
auf süd georgien
vereisten vulkanen
der antarktik
wie funktioniert überleben an den gästen
ragten der welt begleiten sie andreas
kieling auf seiner reise ins
südpolarmeer zu den wildesten und
geheimnisvollsten orten unserer erde
[Musik]
andreas hat sich viel vorgenommen
von patagonien aus liegt eine rund 5000
kilometer lange reise vor ihm zu den
kältesten orten der welt
über kap horn geht es zu den falkland
inseln
weiter nach süd georgien
und schließlich richtung antarktis
[Musik]
wo genau die gegend anfängt und aufhört
weiß keiner
patagonien gehört zu den menschen ersten
orten südamerikas und bis heute zu den
unbekanntesten
ich habe mal wieder riesenglück gehabt
gerade in und um rheine angekommen
das ist dieser nationalpark an der
grenze zwischen schnell und schon sich
in dieser wahnsinnigen wirtschaft das
erste konnten das sind die drei
berühmten 10 wo alle bergsteiger drauf
wollen die einheimischen indianer nennen
die knapp 3000 meter hohen granit berge
türme des blauen himmels und der macht
seinem namen heute alle ehre
dieser leicht zerzauste vertreter ist
der wild lebende urvater des lamas
er gehört zur familie der kamele wie
alle kamele sind guanakos reine
pflanzenfresser und futtern in möglichst
kurzer zeit möglichst viele gräser und
kräuter verdaut wird später beim
wiederkäuen das ist das problem bei
flucht ihren eine zeit lang vertrauen
sie einen erstmal und dann wenn die
tiere aber alleine stehen und eigentlich
zurückwollen zu ihrer gruppe haben sie
dann manchmal das gefühl panik kommt auf
es könnte doch ein fressfeind sei das
granato entspannt sich schnell von
seinem haupt feind nummer eins dem puma
ist weit und breit nichts zu sehen
andreas erkundet die gegend
[Musik]
jetzt war ehrlich das schöne als jede
bundesgartenschau oder starten vor rund
14.000 jahren endete hier die letzte
eiszeit seitdem ziehen sich die
gletscher zurück
viele tiere haben sich angesiedelt
andreas trifft of numbers die größten
vögel der neuen welt die hähne werden
stattliche 1 meter 40 hoch mit den
harmlos aussehenden laufvögeln ist nicht
zu spaßen
bei gefahr teilen sie mit ihren klauen
füßen kräftige tritte aus man sollte
einen bogen um sie machen
erst recht wenn sie ihre küken im
schlepptau haben das stinktier wird
angezählt und macht sich aus dem staub
mit den guanakos dagegen vertragen sich
die nandus gut
bei ankunft der spanier im fünfzehnten
jahrhundert gab es von den neuen welt
kamelen noch 50 millionen
heute ist nur noch ein prozent übrig sie
wurden gnadenlos gejagt wegen ihres
fells und weil man das land für
weidevieh brauchte
[Musik]
guanakos leben in familienverbänden die
tragzeit dauert ein jahr
ein einziges junges wird groß gezogen
wie auf kommando hören alle aufzufressen
ein puma taucht in der nähe auf
die große koalition sich heidt pumas
sind selten und stehen unter schutz
trotzdem zahlen viele farmer immer noch
kopfgeld für jeden abschuss
diesmal haben alle glück gehabt
andreas verlässt patagonien von ushuaia
fährt er jetzt richtung kap horn
[Musik]
nicht einmal 400 meter hoch ist die
landspitze auf der chilenischen
felseninsel isla hornos ein hügelchen in
wahrheit einer der gefährlichsten orte
der welt
das hier hinter mir ist ja vor ein zwei
jahren zusammen der pazifische und das
land sich im sturm aber es sind viele
vögel da in erster linie als großen
albatrosse nicht der starke wind nichts
aus im gegenteil sie nutzen ihn
mancher extrem flieger legt für eine
einzige mahlzeit 15.000 kilometer zurück
ohne zwischenstopp
forscher wissen von einem albatros der
die erde in weniger als 46 tagen einmal
komplett umrundet hat mehr als 20.000 km
davon siegeln
wissenschaftler der tu münchen wollten
herausfinden wie die meister segler das
machen wir haben ihre ergebnisse
animiert
[Musik]
im flug dreht sich der albatrosse nah
über der wasseroberfläche in den wild
wie bei einem startenden flugzeug
bekommt er durch den gegenwind auf seine
flüge haben eine spannweite von 350 dann
fliegt er einen bogen
mit dem wind im rücken gleich wird er
zurück
[Musik]
bei der unteren ende verliert er energie
hier herrscht weniger wind oben bläst
der wind dann wieder stärker deshalb
verbucht der meister segler in jedem
glide zyklus ein energie plus genau das
bringt ihm vor an den albatrossen mut
das wetter vor cacau
den menschen schadet es
hier regnet es an 280 tagen im jahr hier
steigt das thermometer selten über 10
grad
hier würde selbst der teufel erfrieren
schrieb charles darwin einst über den
unscheinbaren felsen am ende der welt
mehr als 800 schiffswracks liegen rund
um kap horn einem der größten schiffs
friedhöfe der welt
sie erzählen von gigantischen
wellenbergen in denen zehntausende
menschen ihr leben verloren
die meisten ihrer geschichten sind heute
vergessen geschichten wie die von carla
s
vor mehr als 100 jahren hatte der
hamburger reeder eine vision und dies
die größte segelschiff leute der welt
bauen
die fliegenden p liner
[Musik]
original aufnahmen zeigen den vier mast
seglerpaar ein wunderwerk der technik
anstatt aus holz waren rumpf deck und
masken aus stahl
[Musik]
am 4 bis zu 62 meter hohen stahlmasten
setzten die matrosen gewaltige segel
mit seinem robusten segelschiffen wollte
leist dem wetter vor kap hoorn trotzen
der seeweg hamburg süd amerika sollte
sicherer werden
[Musik]
was kaum einer für möglich gehalten
hätte gelangen allein die paar mir
umsegelte das todbringende cup 18 mal
ohne nennenswerte verluste die fähigsten
kapitäne und besten matrosen machten
dies möglich
durch seine lukrativen guano und
salpeter fahrten wurde lies damals
weltberühmt
scheinbar mühelos trotzen albatrosse
diesen naturgewalten
vor kap hoorn brüllt der wind an vier
von fünf tagen mehr als dass er heute
wir zeigen ihnen wie über einen zeitraum
von mehreren monaten sehr kalte luft aus
der antarktis an einer scharfen frontal
zone mit wärmerer meeresluft aus dem
norden zusammen breit
die enormen temperaturunterschiede
erzeugen starke tiefdruckgebiete aus
denen bei uns sich ausgedehnte sturm und
orkan felder auf und die können sich
mangels landmasse ungebremst aus ton
mindestens zweimal pro woche das war
wieder ein ordentlicher kaventsmann die
wellen sind mittlerweile über zehn meter
hoch an soll es eine fahrt in den
frühsommer werden
wir befinden uns auf den weg zu den
falkland inseln aber hier im seegebiet
der roaring forties der brüllenden 40 er
weiß man nie genau was einen erwartet
momentan herrscht windstärke 11 13 ist
orkan und da kommt schon der nächste
brecher rund 800 kilometer führt der weg
über das stürmische meer
die vor clans bestehen aus 750 kleinen
und großen insel
hier besucht andreas sie leihen eiland
ein wahrer koloss und ein
mittagsschläfchen am strand
eindringlinge interessieren ihn nicht
am ganzen küstenabschnitt liegen see
elefanten im 10 grad kalten wasser herum
wir würden bei diesen temperaturen
gerade mal einem zähen zu erhalten
hier fühlen sich sogar die dickhäuter
babys sichtlich wohnen
die seele fanden jungen sind jetzt
zweieinhalb bis drei monate alt ihre
mütter haben sie mit drei wochen
verlassen seitdem sind sie alleine die
kommen auch nicht mehr zurück die tiere
sind aber konstant weiter gewachsen vor
allem hat sich hier fällt verändert und
jetzt sind sie so weit dass sie das
erste mal ins wasser gehen können sie
wegen bereits 200 kilogramm und fangen
schon als kleinkinder mit machtspielen
an die elefanten kommen nur zweimal im
jahr an halt so fortpflanzungszeit und
später noch einmal um ihr feld zu
wechseln andreas trifft auf eine gruppe
halbstarker
obwohl er schon ein recht stattliches
exemplar ist ist er noch kein
ausgewachsener elefantenbulle das heißt
dass hier sind alles menschen die so
drei bis fünf jahre alt sind
sie fangen jetzt an ihr feld zu wechseln
das interessante bei see elefanten ist
sie wechseln nicht nur das fell sondern
gleichzeitig die oberhaut 30 bis 40 tage
dauert der fellwechsel und was tun
jugendliche besonders gern wenn sie sich
langweilen
in kleinen scheinen kämpfen ihre kräfte
messen
eine gute übung für später
sie wollen dass werden dass er ist ein
strand meister
er ist der führende harems bulle am
platz erst mit acht bis zehn jahren hat
er genug kraft und genug auf den rippen
um sein revier zu verteidigen
wer einem solchen fleischberg in die
quere kommt auch nichts zu lachen
mit rund vier tonnen zählt er zu den
schwergewichten falk ländern
die reise durch südpolarmeer geht weiter
richtung süd georgien zum abschied von
den falkland inseln kommt besuch eine
große schule corazon der 4
sie gehören zu den kleinsten der vielen
der welt es gibt die nur auf der
südhalbkugel die auffällig gemusterten
meister schwimmer haben das wellenreiten
quasi erfunden
die artenvielfalt am rand des kältesten
und lebensfeindlich stn r teils ist
außerordentlich
auf seinem weg richtung süd georgien
passiert andreas die nordgrenze des
südpolarmeer die sogenannte meinardus
linie oder auch antarktische konvergenz
hier singt kaltes wasser aus der
antarktis unter warmes oberflächenwasser
aus dem norden ab dadurch ändert sich
temperatur und chemische zusammensetzung
des wassers ideale bedingungen für zarte
garnelen artige wesen und arktischer
grill
milliarden dieser leuchtenden
krebstierchen bilden hier gigantische
schwärmen
das mehr an kleinst lebewesen ein
gefundenes fressen für viele
meeresbewohner wie die südlichen
buckelwale
im frühjahr zu beginn der grill
hochsaison ziehen sie in südpolarmeer
beim abtauchen nach der wahl einen
katzenbuckel dem verdankt er seinen
namen
buckelwale gelten als die kraftpakete
unter dem wahl
sie sind akrobatischen strenger und
haben große freude daran mit ihren
übergroßen flippern auf dem
wasseroberfläche zu schlagen
eine theorie besagt die lauten
knallgeräusche locken artgenossen bis
zum weltweiten fangverbot in den 60er
jahren standen buckelwale kurz vor dem
aussterben
heute gibt es auf der südhalbkugel
wieder rund 50.000 tiere
süd georgien besteht aus einer großen
hauptinsel und einigen kleinen
vorgelagerten inseln auch hier besucht
andreas mehrere ort
eine gebirgige zerklüftete landschaft
meist von schnee bedeckt
selbst im antarktischen frühling ist das
klima kühl und feucht
sonnenstunden sind hier die große
ausnahme
sogar jetzt klettert das thermometer
selten über 6 grad
unwirklich menschen leer und verlassen
zell süd georgien zu einem der schönsten
tierparadies
hier gibt es die größten königs
pinguinkolonie in der welt ein
kuscheliger kindergarten
soweit das auge reicht
[Musik]
auch südgeorgien zeigt sich von seiner
schokoladenseite fast 100000
königspinguinen paare brüten allein im
source intensiver fischgeruch erfüllt
die eisige luft
inmitten ja schönen könige see elefanten
in kampfes stiller
jetzt läuft die brunft auf hochtouren
rücksicht ist fehl am platz die bullen
befinden sich in einem wahren
testosteron raus
die strand meister sind fast
ununterbrochen im einsatz
dieser gönnt sich eine kurze
verschnaufpause
wohlverdient die ständigen kämpfe zehren
an den kräften
in dieser zeit fressen die bullen
wochenlang nichts mit 14 jahren sterben
sie deutlich früher als die weibchen ein
leben als bulle ist kein vergnügen
egal wohin andreas blickt überall gibt
es etwas zu entdecken
erwachsene königspinguine sind von natur
aus bestens für temperaturen von minus
vier bis maximal plus zehn grad im
hochsommer ausgestattet trotzdem scheuen
sie jeden wechsel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein das macht keinen spaß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bonndorf hilft ja nichts sie müssen
futter für ihre sprösslinge organisiert
draußen im meer kann es schon mal
gefährlich werden an land hat der
königspinguine keine natürlichen feinde
eigentlich
übrigens das hier gehört hier nicht hin
das ist noch aus den zeiten der ja der
siedler hier
da hat man nämlich rentiere ausgesetzt
und das ist das geweih von einem rentier
ich habe schon mehrere tiere hier hinten
in den bergen gesehen
eigentlich will man die hier nicht um
1910 dienten die eindringlinge aus dem
hohen norden walfängern als
frischfleisch vorrat eine gute idee doch
in den folgenden jahrzehnten vermehrten
sich die kälteerprobten rentiere
dramatisch 6600 herumtrampelt vierbeiner
auf einer insel mit millionen von
seevögeln die auf dem boden brüten ein
riesenproblem
inzwischen wurden alle rentiere
abgeschossen
eine drastische maßnahme der behörden
zum schutz der heimischen fauna
andreas macht sich auf den weg nach
drücken mit den beginnenden frühsommer
ziehen hier südlichen glattwale zur
nahrungssuche richtung antarktis
die imposanten riesen werden bis zu 18
meter lang und 80 tonnen schwerer das
entspricht 67 mittelklasseautos
auffallend sind die haut wucherungen im
kopfbereich der tiere sie sind über und
über mit seepocken und wahllosen bedeckt
männliche wale haben imposante
wucherungen und tragen immer mehr
parasiten berger als die weibchen wie
viele ihrer artgenossen sind diese ware
äußerst neugierig und gesellig und
schwimmen gerne an
genau das wurde ihnen früher zum
verhängnis
andreas erreicht gut wie die offizielle
hauptstadt sind georgiens ist heute eine
geisterstadt
bis auf den besuch von touristen auch
die meiste zeit im jahr menschen mehr
die verfallenen industrieruinen in
dieser schroffen kargen landschaft sind
stumme zeugen eines dunklen kapitels der
geschichte wo heute robben ahnungslos
vor rostigen schiffen dösen fand ab 1904
ein unglaubliches gemetzel stadt
mitwirken war die erste von mehreren
industriellen walfang stationen im
südpolarmeer alleine hier wurden bis zum
fangverbot mitte der 60er jahre
175000 wahler abgeschlachtet dann lohnt
das geschäft nicht mehr weil tran wurde
durch erdöl ersetzt bis dahin hatte man
die größten lebewesen der erde nahezu
ausgerottet
walfänger waren die ersten menschen die
die antarktis besiedelten geblieben ist
keiner
langsam erobert sich die natur diesen
schreckens ort zurück
im äußersten südosten südgeorgien
schneidet sich der drygalski und tief in
die insel ein
gemünden gleich mehrere gletscher ins
meer
der imposante meeresarm verdankt seinen
namen einem deutschen gericht dagobert
von drygalski leiter der ersten
deutschen antarktis expedition von 1901
bis 1903
[Musik]
noch fühlen sich hier krabben fresser
robben wohl aber auch auf südgeorgien
sketchen fließt viel mehr eis ins meer
ab als durch schneefall neu entsteht
die natur wird sich drastisch verändern
ein gewaltiger vorgang der nach ansicht
von forschern nicht mehr zu stoppen ist
jetzt liegen vor andreas nur noch drei
tage bis zum ziel
der antrag des mit prognosen für starke
winde und unruhige see
in der nacht erreicht der wind
orkanstärke
mal wieder
bis zu sieben meter hoher wellen berge
sich auf
im morgengrauen kündig das treibeis an
praktiker ist erreicht
eine wundervolle eishaus welt in den
unglaublichsten farben und formen
[Musik]
bis ins 20 jahrhundert hinein galt der
sechste kontinent als der letzte
unbekannte fleck der erde
hinter den teilweise bis zu 3500 meter
hohen gebirgen liegt das größte
zusammenhängende eisfeld der welt ein
riesiges kaltes nichts sehnsuchtsort
viele abenteurer
der engländer robert falcon scott war
ein großer unternehmen
1910 bis 1912 unternahm er seinen
zweiten versuch den geografischen südpol
zu erreichen
er hatte einen ehrgeizigen gegenspieler
den norweger roald amundsen
der wollte zur gleichen zeit den südpol
erobern
amazon setzte auf 100 robuste grünland
schlittenhunde
[Musik]
sein konkurrent gott kannte sich mit
schlittenhunden nicht aus er setzte auf
man syrische ponys eine entscheidung die
er später bitter bereut zusätzliche
motorschlitten versagten schon am anfang
der reise die technik in kinderschuhen
war den extremen wetterbedingungen nicht
gewachsen
auch die promis kamen mit der kälte
nicht zurecht 1 mit dem anderen starb
auf dem 1300 kilometer langen marsch
doch scott gab nicht auf mit vier
männern seiner mannschaft setzte er
seinen weg fort zu fuß
er kam sogar an am 17 januar 1912
erreichte er sein ziel
dort steckte bereits die norwegische
flagge
niedergeschmettert stellte es gott fest
dass er das rennen gegen armin verloren
hatte
nach mehreren wochen überlebenskampf
starben er und seine begleiter auf dem
rückweg
der südlichste punkt der erde
so sieht er heute aus die amundsen scott
südpol stationen bei durchschnittlichen
temperaturen von minus 46 grad wird hier
seit 1957 geforscht
glaziologen treffen meteorologen
astronomen und astrophysiker ihr
irdisches gemüsebauern sie selbst an
mit dem blick in den himmel erhoffen
sich die forscher mehr über die
kosmische mikrowellen-
hintergrundstrahlung herauszufinden
sie gilt als beleg für die
urknalltheorie
je nachdem wie oft und lange die sonne
scheint treten polarlichter in
erscheinen die sonnenwind teilchen
werden bis zu 3.000.000 stundenkilometer
schnell und vom magnetfeld der erde zu
den polen gelenkt
dort leuchten polarlichter bis weit in
den weltraum
seit 2000 jahren sehen verschiedenste
kulturen in dem himmlischen schauspiel
einen beweis für die anwesenheit von
göttern und geistern zurück auf der erde
jetzt im antarktischen frühling schafft
ist die sonne endlich wieder über den
horizont
nach sechs monaten dunkelheit
[Musik]
andreas nähert sich den südlichen
shetland-inseln dauerfrost ob das schiff
in ein eisiges gewand gekleidet
er ist neben dem schwertwal das
beherrschende raubtier der region
der see leopard
dieses stattliche exemplar macht erstmal
ein verdauungs schlecht
[Musik]
andreas erkundet haben nun einen und
absam not mit dem wetterumschwung
gerade noch lagen die temperaturen bei
minus fünf grad mild für antarktische
verhältnisse
er glaubt dass das wetter ihr den ganzen
tag gleich ist er herzlich eben noch
schien die sonne
und jetzt haben wir ein blizzard mit
windgeschwindigkeiten um die 130
stundenkilometer hier wird jeder
neuankömmling unter die lupe genommen
ab dem frühsommer besiedeln krabben
fresser den rand des packeises sie sind
die einzigen robben der welt die sich
ausschließlich von krill ernähren
neben pinguinen gehören sie zu den
charakteristischen tieren der antarktis
andreas fährt nach deception island
die insel besteht aus einem vulkan und
einem überfluteten krater
bis heute ist der vulkan aktiv und 1970
das letzte mal ausgebrochen
diese mehr engel wird neptuns blasebalg
genannt es ist einer der wenigen orte
auf der welt wo schiffe direkt in einen
krater see fahren können
andreas erkundet die caldera den kessel
des vulkans alles wirkt harmlos ruhig
das täuscht im achtzehnten neunzehnten
und zwanzigsten jahrhundert war er
besonders aktiv aktuell wird das risiko
eines ausbruchs von wissenschaftlern als
relativ hoch eingestuft
den tieren ist das egal
ausgerechnet hier haben sich zügel
pinguine angesiedelt und denen ist
wirklich kein weg zu steil
[Musik]
da oben wollen sich warum nehmen
pinguine eigentlich diese kraxelei auf
sich klettern ein kilometer den berg
hoch bald sind dann von dort oben ihre
nester müssen das ganze futter wird hoch
schleppen
es gibt nur eine erklärung an den
berghängen
wen immer sehr starke winde und diesen
am schnellsten schnee und eis frei
erzählt etwas unwirklich aus wie eine
seelen kulisse doch hier tobt echtes
zügel pinguin leben auf deception island
bilden sie mit 100.000 haben die
weltweit größte brutkolonie es wird
geballert was das zeug hält
[Musik]
die bindung der partner ist sehr stark
oft kommt es vor dass sie sich in den
darauffolgenden jahren erneut paaren
andreas kann die zügel pinguine beim
nestbau beobachten
generell geben sie sich nicht zu viel
mühe wie ihre verwandtschaft aber
immerhin sammeln sie eine menge umher
liegende vulkan steinchen aus denen sie
eine art brut plattform bauen
[Musik]
das reicht noch nicht es müssen mehr
steinchen
[Musik]
manch einer nimmt den mund dabei ganz
schön
[Musik]
wir zeigen ihnen wie gut es den zügen
pinguinen bis in die 80er jahre ging
damals waren es rund 7,5 millionen
brutpaare
es gab weniger wale und dadurch grill im
überschuss in den letzten 20 jahren
schrumpfte die population dramatisch
teilweise bis zu 75 prozent
experten vermuten zügel pinguine kommen
schlecht mit der globalen klimaerwärmung
klar wurden auf den süd shetlandinseln
1987 noch 25 millionen brutpaare gezählt
sind es heute weniger als eine million
obwohl sie selbst auf einem aktiven
vulkanen klarkommen
der größte und historisch aktivste
vulkan der antarktis ist meint airbus
er liegt im westen der insel und ist der
südlichste vulkan unseres planeten mount
erebus ist ununterbrochen aktiv und
trotzdem immer vereist
dieses eindrucksvolle naturschauspiel
hat die vorstellung des menschen über
die antarktis geprägt
sie ist beides ort ist feuers und des
ewigen eises und sie ist der kälteste
ort der welt
2010 betrug die tiefste jemals auf der
erde in freier natur gemessene
temperatur minus 93,2 grad
die antrag des steckt voller extreme
nirgendwo sonst fällt so wenig
niederschlag wie hier
sie ist die größte wüste und einer der
wichtigsten orte unseres planeten die
vig geschwindigkeiten erreichen hier bis
zu 320 kilometer pro stunde
das ist weit mehr als in einem hurrikan
vor rund 50 millionen jahren herrschte
hier statt einer steifen brise aber eher
ein laues lüftchen damals hat die
antarktis komplett anders aus frost gab
es nicht es herrschte ein nahezu
tropisches klima bei einer mittleren
jahrestemperatur von fast 20 grad wuchs
an den küsten üppiger regenwald
verwandte der heutigen bäume und palmen
im laufe von 20 millionen jahren kühlte
das klima ab vor 34 millionen jahren
verschwand der sechs kontinenten
innerhalb kurzer zeit unter einem
kilometer dicken eisschicht
das machte einen ungeheuren
entwicklungsschub für wale und pinguine
möglich
wir sind in der nähe der antarktischen
halbinsel hier bahnen sich
kaiserpinguine ihren weg ihre
brutkolonien liegen gewöhnlich auf
meereis teilweise bis zu 200 km vom
wasser entfernt
[Musik]
die kaiser sind die einzigen wirbeltiere
die hier längere zeit leben können
morgen zu erfrieren
sehnsüchtig werden die ankömmlinge
erwartet von den niedlichen küken unter
den pinguinen
kaiserpinguine gelten als die schönsten
pinguine der welt und als besonders
fürsorgliche eltern
[Musik]
das könnte ins auge gehen
jetzt sei er gerade noch mal gut
gegangen
kaiserpinguin küken sind mit besonders
flauschigem gefieder ausgestattet eine
fast perfekte isolierung gegen die kälte
[Musik]
immer schließen sich mehrere küken in
einer art hort zusammen
[Musik]
das ist nicht so langweilig und auch
viel kuscheliger
[Musik]
ein paar elterntieren spielen erzieher
und passen bei kleinen ausflügen auf die
sprösslinge aus
[Musik]
andere kaiserpinguine brüten noch ihre
füße sind nur oben wo das ei legt stark
durchblutet das wärmt schön
für den wechsel haben die eltern nur
wenige sekunden zeit
sonst stirbt der embryo ab
geschafft jetzt ist das all in
sicherheit
[Musik]
mit gut einem meter sind sie die wahren
kaiser und den pinguinen
vor kurzem haben forscher das 26
millionen jahre alte skelett eines
pinguins gefunden den kairo co er war
gut ein meter vierzig groß 70 kilo
schwer und sah aus wie eine mischung aus
kormoran und pinguin auf seiner reise
hat andreas kaiserpinguin königspinguine
esel zügel und felsenpinguine getroffen
neben dem riesigen krukow sehen sie aus
wie kleine geschwister andreas reise zu
den wildesten und einsamsten orten im
südpolarmeer ist zu ende
eine kalte welt
unglaublich
[Musik]
[Applaus]